I got off in the comedy store I'd like
to and then I watched some goofy I've
been on this UFO documentary watching
UFO documentaries
yeah I told you as David I started
talking about it yeah we were talking
about that what were you did you have
something specific that you would saw
recently a documentary one of them is
area area 51 Bob Lazar and Aliev area 51
in flying saucers it's uh some
documentary on this guy who claimed that
he worked on these alien ships in area
51 in the 1980s chills as times gone on
more the things that he said have proven
to actually be true like what including
an element that he talked about element
115 I think it was called like a
organism from outer space no no an
element like a man created element you
know what this carbon right yeah well
there's an element that they created
that he talked about way before it was
ever publicized and he talked about this
thing and then it turned out to be true
he talked about these there's these hand
monitors so you would put your hand on
this thing and these line these metal
lines would detect the distances in the
bones of your fingers the exact
distances and every one is different
it's like a signature thing yeah and
that they could find out if it was you
or not you it was trying to go through
so the way they would scan people that
bio scan would literally measure the
bones and their fingers and people said
that was horseshit why about this in the
1980s people said it was horseshit but
then later on turned out no they did
have that in Los Alamos they did have
that in in area 51 and that this
technology was very very advanced very
not just very advanced but very not it
was not well known at all like very few
people did this guy who was creator of
this documentary was very difficult for
them to get photos of this hand scanner
but this hand scanner did exist and
existed exactly as this guy described it
in the 80s I mean that's super
progressive for that there's also Intel
that did approve his top-secret
clearance to get to this place they know
that he actually worked there there's
people that worked in the same Los
Alamos lab with him they tried to say he
never worked there but his names on the
manifest
it's very strange like they've tried to
erase parts of this guy's past because
he he filmed a bunch of their crafts as
they were flying around like he knew
what days this is the thing that thing
right there you put your hand on that
and it actually measures the distance of
the size and length of your bone that
looks like something that's inside of an
escape room in LA I went into this
documentary skeptical I said yeah but I
am I'm so done with all those things but
listen to this guy talk for a while
after a while I was like what if he's
telling the truth like what if he is
actually telling the truth because if
he's actually telling the truth there is
some part of the government that had
access at least in the 1980s to alien
technology probably is some truth to
that crazier things have happened and
also like just your mentality of
believing him it's probably the same
thing that made dr. Malachi Lovejoy
Robinson the third become successful con
artist yeah I mean either this dude
there's validity of what he's saying in
this documentary which I can't wait to
watch or he's just really great at
painting a picture some people are so
good at convincing you that's true of
truths true there's you know people with
like borderline personality disorder in
every sort of spectrum in between there
they become really good manipulators
that is true however usually they do
that in more than one avenue absolutely
this guy's not doing that
yes documentary event that also hasn't
varied a story like it mean he might
have like changed the way says things in
terms of like the words he chooses but
the actual story is exactly the same as
he was telling a long time ago just a
self-produced documentary there's their
production company no production that's
where it's like okay there's price and
philetus but this guy's been around for
a long time I remember reading about him
and watching videos about him you know
20 years ago I mean don't you think
you're somebody who you said you know
and I know it's about you you you love
space you're you're obsessed with that
the idea of what we are in in the solar
system and beyond like how impossible is
it to think that there could be a
creature that could breach our
atmosphere with some advanced technology
and be able to just sort of chill you
know scoot around
scutes Macoutes check us out and fucking
peace out back up to wherever they think
that's how they would do it but yeah
yeah they just kind of cruise around you
know they're looking at us
well he had an interesting analogy he
said if you brought a an atomic engine
to these people that live in the
Victorian era and said hey this is uh
this is a nuclear power plant like here
here check this out they would fuck with
it they'd wind up getting sick from
radiation they'd wind up dying no one
would understand what it was or how it
worked
they would never figure it out right he
goes why would we assume that this is
only from that one time with this one
device why would we assume that there'd
be some other technology that maybe
we'll create some day in the future I'm
paraphrasing him very poorly it's okay
or someone else
scientists from another planet would
create that we wouldn't understand at
all and he said that's what we were
dealing with when we were trying to back
engineer the propulsion systems that
these things use they use some gravity
based propulsion system and it was
something that would manipulate gravity
in front of it's very look I don't I'm
too stupid to know the science of it I
don't know if he's tell like if you were
scientist you're supposed to know these
named Joseph Rogan degree so I can call
us you should I just want to get an
honorary one like Cosby had it's gone
now you can't keep that actually I think
he wrote an essay and that's how they
gave him his doctorate that's not him
well probably up more than one doctorate
I mean yeah sure he did and he didn't
they didn't deserve them but I think I
mean there's gotta be stuff out there a
hundred percent a hundred percent but I
like to say there's not it's like a stop
you think no no I don't think it is but
it is entirely possible um
I use that phrase too often it's
entirely possible you got to get a
measure of all of those oh it's already
out there yeah
where's 150,000 of them to be honest
possible that are the were the most
advanced ability because something has
to be the most advanced absolutely and
something has to be the least we could
also be on that part of the spectrum or
maybe we're the last to evolve it's a
hundred percent 100 percent possible and
if there's if there's an infinite number
of life-forms out there like if there's
an infinite number of planets there's an
infinite number of earth-like planets
that could you know have beings like us
on it who's to say that we're not the
most advanced maybe they're all like
people from the 1820s yeah shit they're
still doing you know I'll think the
chisel stone and chisels but I'm talking
like old old shit they don't even have
pens and papers yet like the orangutan
is out fishing with a spear exactly
there's just a bunch of advanced
orangutangs that are like you know
putting hieroglyphics and caves it's
possible it is very possible totally
possible but cuz we're just we're just
basing it off of our own experience and
perception of what we have been exposed
to no idea you know the other really
interesting scenario is that there are
time travelers
oh really and that's exciting what they
are is some being from the far distant
future that understands that it could
come back and observe us and see like
where things went wrong where things
went right but do so in a way that's as
minimally intrusive as possible and
occasionally interfere that's things